it's time to babble the [__] on
[Music]
we got a lot of good show in store for
you tonight kids but i had to address
this before we go any further i saw it
all over the interwebs and i said i'm
gonna ask that guy about that okay
apparently he's got money to burn these
days did you make any interesting
purchases recently i did ralph as a
matter of fact uh they just announced
today back home uh where i'm from ladies
and gentlemen the great state of new
jersey uh in new jersey can i get a
little more volume on this mike i feel
like i'm working too hard
it's never been the case for you [__]
suddenly i was like [__] is that what
it's like to put the pedal in the middle
uh they announced uh thanks to an
interview i did uh with the the newark
star ledger
uh one of our uh the greatest papers in
new jersey
that uh the first uh on first avenue
atlantic islands was movie theater uh
when i was a kid it was called the
atlantic islands movie theater then they
added a screen
like in the early 80s i think it's 1983
they added a second screen became the
atlantic highlands twin cinema and there
was no cable or [__] internet back
then so when they added a second screen
that was like the biggest thing that
ever happened to our world and that
second screen still exists i was just
back there in that theater that's where
i saw scarface wow for the [__] first
time as a 13 year old boy
no better time to see it oh my god it
was amazing once they added a second
theater you could hop theaters right you
can pay to see one movie and then
[__] sneak into the other movie
[__] outlaw hell yeah man that's why
i went to work for the movie business
because i heard it for so long as a
child yes you owe me you owe them i went
to see scarface me and john kovic man
we're 13 years old we're two [__]
students at our lady of perpetual help
but we want to go see this movie and so
we pay to see something else we sneak in
to see that movie my parents dropped us
off well my mom's my dad slept because
he worked at nights and [__] so my mom
drops us off ms kovic who just recently
sadly passed away uh she was picking up
me and john so we're sitting in that
theater by ourselves because it was like
a week night and [__] and there we are
watching scarface and we felt like holy
[__] we had the place to ourselves like
we owned the movie theater and watching
this [__] massive adventure with tons
of [__] expletives and [__] two
catholic school kids were getting away
with [__] murder ralph
murder and then you know we all know the
movie and [__] at a certain point his uh
his wife his sister gina shows up after
he brings her home after spoilers he
kills
manny his best friend who she secretly
married and [__] like that right now i
guess i won't watch it now thanks a lot
kevin i tell you that even the best part
of scarface but anyway
so you know uh that scene is going on
where she comes in and mary elizabeth
master tony and she's wearing like the
robe that's open she's got like panties
on and [__] and she's walking on she's
all like [__] in a state of shock
just [__] up because she just watched
she watched her brother kill her [__]
husband and [__] and so she's like
talking to him all like uh innocent and
[__] and then all of a sudden she like
pulls out a gun and starts trying to
shoot him she's like you want to [__] me
tony [__] me tony and she's doing that
[__] this is when john jonkovic's mother
walked into the theater oh jesus
she come early to pick us up she went
looking for us we weren't in the other
theater she came we were watching herbie
the love bug no [__] we were watching a
dude's sister say you want to [__] me
tony right before he buried his face in
a pile of cocaine and killed 40 [__]
people and [__] mrs kovic was horrified
to say the least
stormed out of the [__] theater i
looked to john i was like should we go
he's like no wait and we wanted to see
the end of the movie then we went home
the ride home was very quiet and i
remember she was just like john i'm
disappointed in you kevin i expected
this yeah
[Laughter]
so i said you wanna [__] me kevin do you
want to [__] me kevin
i was like oh my god you do lines with
movies too
so uh i've been going to that movie
theater my whole life my dad used to
take me there and stuff uh i i you know
i
went there all throughout high school
that was the friday night
uh haunt and um recently we went back
there uh this weekend i was back home in
new jersey for my birthday
jay's birthday is in june as you know
and my birthday is in august but we
combine them onto my birthday and uh
came up with we didn't even come up with
lily in the office came up with it uh
she's an accountant i think only an
accountant could come up with this gag
well quick math yes
she goes well jay turned 48 in june and
you're turning 52. that's 100 years of
jay and silent bob
so that's what we called it 100 years of
jay and silent bob we took pictures then
we did a show at night at the atlantic
uh what's now called the atlantic movie
house um we did jane's and sound bob
good old their main theater is how many
is this c uh 200 i think 200 so they see
250 so it's slightly larger than this
but it's a movie theater it's not
[__] set up like a bar or you know
everyone
i guess everyone is facing the [__]
screen in the movie there
much different think about it
so uh we did our show there and i was
having a blast and whatnot and uh i i've
been uh doing some stuff in the theater
for like the last six months we me and
ernie o'donnell who uh built smod castle
my little podcast theater uh back in
leonardo that's at the end of the quick
stop block of stores and stuff 50 seat
theater we got
um he hit me up one day where he's just
like they're they're selling the
atlantic highlands movie theater and
ashley uh ashley who runs the lilu
multi-props which is a company i've
worked with he signed [__] they
refurbished props and [__] they found
like a [__] hand from beetlejuice the
shrimp hand and stuff oh yeah they got
like an amazing collection of [__] so
anyway ashley
uh
was like in the market to buy some
[__] real estate i've never done [__]
like this i bought a house and that's
about it and stuff and then years later
i helped my kid [__] buy a house by
going through the paperwork and was like
now i remember why i never did this more
than [__] months
but you know suddenly we were like wait
a second there's a chance that we could
actually
buy our
teenage
childhood movie theater and [__] turn
that into from you know smart castle
theater to smart castle cinemas go from
having a [__] 50-seater to
five screens of various [__] size
that don't need me to succeed it's a
living breathing movie theater and has
been for literally almost 100 years wow
yeah the building is over 100 years old
and [__] so
it's a business that's up and running
don't always need me there for it but
it's also a business that i could
augment men like most movie theaters
could just show movies i can bring
hollywood babylon there and [__] you
know 50 bucks a seat and bam we're
[__] in business 50 bucks not you
know because we have to travel [__]
east you guys get off lights yeah
just remember that you get the friends
and family discount because you're local
next time your fingers hovering over the
button going do i want to watch those
guys again
realizing new jersey like 50 bucks i
gotta do it and [__]
so we can run live shows we can run
music stand-up [__] comedy i have the
ability to monetize the movie theater in
ways that most movie theaters don't
traditionally though like look it's hard
enough keeping lights on just [__]
showing movies
and stuff when you own a movie theater
you you're really not you're in the
movie business but technically as you
know you're in the candy selling
business it's concessions
i got to make sure that it's a little
better than that for us and that's what
i can bring to the table by being like
all right let's [__] do this this and
this
so um you know
it
for the last few months we've been going
back and forth now in contract phase and
september 14th we close on it i'm going
to co-own a movie theater in atlantic
highlands pretty cool
the one i grew up going to the movies at
so
naturally will one screen just be
showing yoga hosers all the time yes
[__]
absolutely are you kidding me that's
because that one screen is just
dedicated to yoga hoses
on a continuous loop that's the thing
man my movies have gotten so [__] bad
that no one will play him i had to buy a
movie theater
to show my movies now so god damn it
nothing can stop yoga hosers at this
point
um no man i i can't wait i look forward
to in the big bad way there's uh like
plans
afoot like crazy i know we're gonna do
film series of all my stuff naturally
[__] you're you're joking but [__]
tusk yoga hosers kilroy was here we'll
be in permanent midnight rotation on the
weekends and stuff
um but also the uh the you know you i'm
a manufacturer for use guy like i can't
just
just buying a movie theater is vanity
like you know
because it's a business that seems to be
dying elsewhere yeah a lot of movie
theaters obviously closed during the
pandemic film exhibition is a you know
losing footing unless you're a marvel
movie it's really tough to get people to
come out to the theaters and stuff so
aside from just like all right showing
movies and bringing shows to it you know
i'm like how else do i monetize the
space so instantly i started writing a
movie about it like if you own a movie
theater write a movie set at the [__]
movie theater which is something i've
always wanted to do so i was talking
about last episode the part that i wrote
for ralph and stuff uh it's a movie that
takes place in 1986 it's like a little
memoir about my youth and it's about how
we used to go to the movie theaters and
[__] jump around hop theaters skip
and sneak from movie into movies so it's
a movie about sneaking around the movie
theater all day with three kids it's
called the 430 movie and we're going to
start shooting it at the top of 2023 so
buying a movie theater
created the next movie
that i'll show in the [__] movie
theater
ralph the snake's not just eating its
tail it's blowing itself now at the same
time
but this is what what really excites me
though is that you should gouge the
production company for the location fee
that's what you should do i'm gonna be
like a million dollars um what i'm very
excited about though is like for years
you know we've been trying to figure out
how to get ralph to
to jersey to do babylon at smod castle
problem is it's 50 seats and you know
you've got to charge people in order to
fly ralph out put him up give him money
for his time in the show and performance
and [__] you know you got to make a
fairly decent nut that
40 seats 50 seats is never gonna [__]
cover unless you're charging people a
hundred dollars a [__] seat and you
know we had a lot of people back east
who were like i'll [__] pay it and i
was like jesus man i'm like [__] you
see me all the time like not for you
[__] garmin
[Laughter]
so now makes me feel bad yeah totally
now with 250 seats it's easier to like
we could fill an auditorium like twice
do two shows and pay for ralph's [__]
first class passage
that's what he demands on his rider kids
that's what i call cocaine
my first class package
um so yeah ma'am we'll be we'll be doing
uh i i look if i can get you to do it
man i would i'm hoping you commit to at
least buy monthly shows which sounds
exactly as sexy as i mean it but if not
monthly [__] shows we go back and and
we do two shows on a friday or saturday
night or something like that walk away
with enough scratch cover all the
airline and [__] make as much money
as we do here if not i mean no no
disrespect to flappers more [__]
money man
more because we can gouge those east
coasters because we're making the
[__] trip and [__] like that
i mean you said the quiet part out loud
i did i did
[__] the plan's been spoiled no uh i'll
tell you this though right now uh the
story went up on the uh today at
newjersey.com as the ledger story and uh
so i was playing catch up i didn't
realize it was going up today so i put
up a tweet about and i put up a
instagram post about it
i have
not since the first movie i ever made
and honestly i don't even think we had
100 consensus on that movie but it
seemed like everybody really liked that
[__] [__] first movie they're like i
can't wait to see what he does with the
rest of his career and then yoga so
but it felt like there was like
you know
there was the one point in my career
where most people were like this [__]
guy he's the [__] guy
almost literally 100 consensus from the
audience on this even people who are
like i hate your shitty movies but this
is a [__] awesome move and [__] 100
consensus but
president biden should buy a movie
theater
country would we get 100 behind him like
look he's [__] up on this i don't like
the guy i'm republican but jesus he
bought a movie theater
i'm crazy crazy the amount of love i got
and people are like you're doing a good
thing for the community i was like not
as much as i'm doing for myself like i
bought my childhood movie theater man
like you know i was here's the best part
it's [__] apartment above it that's
where i'm going to live when i'm back
there and [__] i always wanted to live
in a movie theater but i failed i have
to live above the movie theater
you're going to be like phantom of the
opera
for the movie theater absolutely
kevin's gonna come out with a baseball
cap turned around and a mask on
lurk behind the curtains or i'm gonna be
like that old [__] in the last action
hero right where the kid comes in and he
lives in the movie theater and
arnold shows up somehow
holy [__] who's high tonight aren't you
the guy who used to go from theater to
theater in here
holy [__] you might have just given him
the role that i wrote for you [__]
[Applause]
and then yeah i'm just too good for my
own good i know you're everybody's agent
so yeah fun and good times kids like you
got to remember uh four and a half years
ago uh i nearly bit it and shuffled
loose the mortal coil and stuff uh while
i'm above ground you know and and
breathing [__] rarefied air living on
borrowed time i'm just gonna try to keep
doing fun [__] don't hurt anybody some
people do fun [__] ralph where they're
like i'm gonna hunt humans i don't want
to do that [__]
that does sound fun though
sometimes also sounds like [__] very
tiring and [__] uh i just wanna do fun
[__] makes people happy and [__]
nobody dislikes like a movie theater is
what i found [__] if i'd known this i'd
bought one years ago in my career i'd
have bought one every time one of the
movies didn't work out cop-out came out
people like [__] you i'm like i bought a
movie theater
like all right we're back on your side
and [__] well it's perfect for you to
own a movie theater i mean a guy who
loves movies and has loved movies and
has been as vocal about it as you over
the years it's just a perfect match the
uh and he's like me buying a liquor
store yes
and by the way we bought a movie theater
but really in order to do that what i'm
buying is two buildings the movie
theater is contained across two separate
buildings on first avenue and atlantic
island so in one building is the movie
theater proper which has
three theaters yes three theaters and
then above it is the apartment so next
door is another building that we'll be
owning
that in the front of it has nicholas
creamery which is like rock and ice
cream place
has an empty
uh commerce place up front used to be a
bank now it's empty so we're gonna rent
it out then there's offices upstairs and
[__] and then the back of everything are
two more of the theaters so it spills
over from one building into another in
that empty slot you could own your own
liquor store see
and then you could live with me at the
apartment
and it'll be like the odd couple and
[__]
[Applause]
well there's that
i don't remember that version of this
the really odd couple yeah
felix bricking my mouth
um
i can't wait man this could be good
times but here's the thing all my whole
life i always felt well my whole life
but my most of my
young adult life end to now whenever i
go to movies during the day matinees and
stuff you know it's empty as [__] right
it's not like you even on the weekends
it's weekend's more crowded but during
the weekday [__] like you're alone in
the movie theater you could jerk off and
stuff and you know they got to keep the
lights on and and pay everybody and [__]
so i always felt like it was not cost
effective to be open during the day i
was like what could you do the movie
theater during the day clearly at night
from six o'clock on that's when people
go to the movies
weekdays monday to friday what could you
do from [__] like 10 o'clock to five
and i always felt
you know in a movie theater you got a
bunch of seats and you got a screen
that's essentially a classroom classroom
i went to a film school was a movie
theater looking place so i was like [__]
they should all anyone who owns a movie
theater should think about running a
film school so now i own a movie theater
and i've been thinking about that [__]
for years so instantly one of the first
things we started talking about is
opening and this is no [__] next
summer we're going to start it as a
summer camp program but we're going to
open a film school it's called buick
university colon the jay in silent bob
film school
now
not accredited
[Applause]
before film twitter is like you can't
[__] make a movie let alone teach
someone to make a movie
i'm not teaching people how to make a
movie i'm teaching people how to make a
kevin smith movie
and god damn it i know how to do that
right or wrong i know how to make a
kevin smith movie so the idea is we're
gonna do
uh
june july and august
test it out essentially more of like a
film camp or a fantasy camp if you will
a month-long program where you come for
the first week and a half is all
pre-production all your instructors the
people that you're gonna work on the
short film with uh the next week and a
half is we actually make a short film
i'm gonna direct it so you're literally
seeing everything [__] i do and stuff
um and the stars of the short film are
jay and silent bob
and
this is now this ties this is
we were like what do we do each time
what's the theme
and so in the great spirit of abit
costello every shirt is going to be jay
and silent bob meet the monsters
[Laughter]
so that will be the curriculum that's
what we make and then the next week and
a half is post-production and [__] so i
edit with everybody and then we premiere
at the movie theater have fun so that
that feels like you know
i'm not going like hey man
four years of an education and here's
your degree it's but it is very much
like you will see exactly how the [__]
we do it like no mystery we will break
everything down so like when you meet
your instructors it's like the ad is
going to show you how to schedule the dp
is going to like show you everything
that the equipment that they order and
[__] where to get it from ever just make
it so simple so that when you leave you
can replicate the experience under your
own steam if you like so that's the plan
for the [__] future man and who knows
dude maybe we fine like remember roger
corman had a bunch of people make movies
for him some of them grew up to be
[__] opie and [__] like ron howard he
first made it
scorsese yeah exactly so you know it's
it could be a cool thing man it could be
like
you know finding somebody who's the
future of sin i'm clearly not even the
past where i'm just like [__]
somewhere in the ancient history but
like could be involved in
bringing more people to the table you
know it's like i've always said there's
two paths in this life destruction and
creation why not get as many people on
the creation
path as possible and and to do that like
in the lobby right now is all mirrors
like it looks like the [__] speaking
of scarface looks like the club scene in
scarface but frank sinatra puppet gets
killed
just 70s 80s as [__] so we're gonna wrap
it with uh the great nate uh dark nate
returns nick gonzalez who does all the
artwork for our shows and [__] um we're
doing this giant mural that's on the
concessions wall
that tracks every famous [__] who grew
up in trained in new jersey or something
like that like you know obviously
[__] danny devito [__] meryl
streep jack nicholson [__] tom cruise
like so forth and so on
so that when kids come in
they see what's possible when i was a
kid anytime they mentioned new jersey i
was like oh my god we exist they know
about us and [__] made me feel
positively famous walk in see a mural
with all these [__] came from the
same state as you and you're a little
kid you're like this is possible that's
what a [__] movie theater should be a
dream factor it's a dream church where
you go in
and you bring your hopes and you [__]
watch fantasies come true and [__] like
that for just a few hours you believe
you put your faith in something far
bigger than yourself far greater than
yourself and then you know you feel
inspired you go about the rest of your
[__] week same thing so we're
building a [__] a church ralph a
church to film and i'm inviting
everybody to come pray at it
beautiful
with money
[Applause]
just like the real church you should
call it a church and try to get that tax
deal they got going on
man start burying people there and [__]
yeah
it's pretty sweet yeah well
congratulations you're a mogul you've
always been a mini mogul now you're a
mogul mogul
you're like own property and [__] that
that is monopoly come to life it is a mr
moneybag you are
um it's not just me i got partners man
thankfully ashley jeff swanton is
another friend of mine from back home
and stuff uh and ernie of course is
coming over with us and stuff and uh
it's kind of on the back of what he was
able to accomplish with smod castle
which we have such fun time doing [__]
with but it's
limited by its [__] size
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith